Sam when did you know that your voice
that you had the money voice at what age
did you say this I don't want to sell it
until I started getting paid for it I
guess I may never know it I've always
that kind of you know I always think it
was involved in singing in choirs and
vocal ensembles since I was a little kid
all the way through school and high
school in college and you know so I
think I developed it I think a lot of us
genetics you know but it was until a
long long time after that that I did
anything you have to ensure that voice
like Vanna White does her legs
oh no no no Bret talk to us about
casting Sam Elliott how do you decide
that he's the man you on your film well
I think he's the man I think everybody
wants in their film mm-hmm oh you're
gonna cast a real man a true man
I when we wrote the part of bill that
Sam plays he's got to be someone who can
come in and swoop blythe danner off of
her feet and that's not an easy task and
for me Sam was my first choice because
he's the definition of a man but he's
also when you get to know him a very
sensitive guy very sweet and generous
guy then Sam hasn't been hard for you to
sort of maintain your brand
I mean westerns are iconic but you don't
see too many Westerns and as Brett said
you're the definition of a man what is
that what movie makers are saying today
no not to my knowledge no no I mean I
spend a lot of time sitting at home
listening to my commercials you know so
no I don't work all the time I think
that's a real misconception is the
Western dead as a show I don't think it
is I just think it's you know I think
it's been given short shrift by
Hollywood for a long time and I think
they've wasted some money on some really
big blockbuster westerns that didn't do
it any good sir do you like I mean it
was kind of a twist on the Western to
degree but did you like Django I did a
bib yeah I think that I think
Tarantino's Removal genius he's a genius
and he's part of the reason I wanted to
become a filmmaker who wanna make a
Western uh yeah see I actually want to
make a Western with Sam
you want to do anything with them how
much yes how much do you like commercial
work I mean that's got to be easy pay
the great thing about commercial workers
allows me to turn down most of the
movies that come my way I don't have to
work for that you know I mean I can be
picky about the kind of stuff let's give
us the is the banquet beer line live
cures the banquet beer all right what's
your what's your dream role what's your
dream gig this is pretty much a dream
gig running on Bloomberg TV I get that I
feel it every day yeah no is there a
part you love is upon this part is
really as good as it gets for me it was
an opportunity to play a leading man
after I'd been playing these character
parts for a long time and you know it's
good I can get that and you sweep when
it's mom off her feet I mean that's a
good one yeah it's a good piece it's a
great piece of okay this role aside yes
I know there are a lot a lot of Lebowski
fans out there was that your favorite
character all the stranger it we can't
ranked up there what else is out there
we gotta go much